Narrator:
Tonight, Anne Wojcicki,
the billionaire founder
of game‐changing
genetics company 23andMe,
joins the Tank.
I love this space.
It's super hot right now
in Silicon Valley.
[ New York accent ]
Who wants to sell some meat,
or do I gotta break some knees
around here?
Let's go!
This is, like,
next‐level science.
I've hired the top minds
to make this a reality.
The future of fitness is...
How big is the bankruptcy market
in the U. S.?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐It's really, really big.
If you want him to match my deal
and you would pick him,
that you will regret
forever.
[ Thunder rumbles ]
Yeah, baby.
Whoo!
♪♪
Narrator: First in the Tank is
what the entrepreneur believes
is cutting‐edge healthcare
for your loved ones.
♪♪
Aww.
[ Chuckles ]
My name is Aaron Hirschhorn
from Philadelphia, Pennsylvania,
and my company is Gallant.
Take a look
at these little puppies!
Aren't they so cute?
So, I brought one
for each Shark.
Yay!
Okay.
Daymond, that's Bear.
Hey, Bear.
How you doing?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐That's Bunny.
Baby. Aww, hi.
All right.
Hi.
O'Leary: See, if this ‐‐
if this guy pees on me,
it's over between us.
I understand.
It's a risk
I'm willing to take.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Hi, little baby.
That's Panda.
Cuban: And who do I get?
You have Fred.
What up, Fred?
‐Hi.
‐Whatcha doing, Freddy?
Hi! Aww, so sweet.
Hirschhorn: Now,
bear with me for a second.
If you were to fast forward
just 10 short years,
four out of five
of these little guys
are gonna suffer from
devastating age‐related illness,
like arthritis, blindness,
or worse.
[ Thunder rumbles ]
Greiner: Ohhh.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Who's there?
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Cuban: Move along.
Move along.
You ain't touching Fred.
[ Laughter ]
Mine doesn't want
to go.
I'm sorry, buddy, I tried
to buy you out, but no deal.
Panda wanted a royalty.
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: The Grim Reaper.
I'm turning into Robert.
[ Laughter ]
Hirschhorn: Our story begins
two years ago
when I was finally freed
from a decade
of chronic back pain
with stem‐cell therapy.
And at the same time, I watched
our beloved family dog, Rocky,
suffer from arthritis
so painful,
she couldn't even walk.
And I wondered if
the same revolutionary science
that helped my back
could also be used for pets.
Turns out, it can.
So, I created Gallant ‐‐
stem‐cell banking and
regenerative medicine for pets.
Just as you can bank
your children's
umbilical cord stem cells
at birth,
you can now save your pet's
young, healthy stem cells
during a routine spay
or neuter.
All you do is sign up
on our website,
and we send our kit
to your veterinarian
and take care of the rest.
And I'm so excited
about Gallant,
not only because stem cells
treat multiple disorders,
from kidney disease
to broken bones.
In research animals,
they've been shown
to extend healthy life
by as much as 30%.
Imagine that ‐‐ that's years
more with your best friend.
So, Sharks, for $500,000
in exchange
for 2% of the company...
‐Oh!
‐Wow.
Whoa.
...you can join our pack
of stem‐cell scientists
and bring enduring health ‐‐
and puppy love ‐‐
to millions with Gallant.
This is not
gonna end well.
[ Chuckles ]
Well, you must have
fantastic sales, I'm guessing.
So, we have two divisions.
We have
a therapeutics division
that's actively developing
stem‐cell medicines,
and we have a consumer
stem‐cell banking division
that launches in three weeks.
I know how
this is gonna end.
[ Laughs ]
Tell us your history.
Absolutely.
So, in 2009,
my wife and I each lost
our jobs,
and we started dog sitting
in our house
to make extra money.
[ Chuckles ]
And that turned into an online
platform for dog sitting.
Think Airbnb for dogs.
‐Mm‐hmm.
And we generated
over $100 million in sales
in under six years.
What?
What? $100 million?
Wow.
We merged with a competitor
two years ago,
and that's now
worth $925 million.
What was the name
of the company?
John: Wow.
My company was called
DogVacay,
and now it's called Rover.
Wow.
But what was
your background training?
In college,
I was a neuroscience major.
I was a high‐school
science teacher as my first job,
but this is, like,
next‐level science.
I mean, what I've done here
is I've hired the top minds
in the field of veterinary
regenerative medicine
to make this a reality.
So, we have four key patents
that essentially
lock competitors out of this...
You do?
...multi‐billion‐dollar
market.
What does it cover,
technically?
Yeah, so, if I may
just back up
and explain a little bit
about how stem cells work.
Yeah.
So, just the same way
a lizard,
like, regrows its tail,
we have stem cells
in every tissue of our body,
and they're responsible
for regenerating.
Now, the problem is,
as you get older,
your store of stem cells
go down dramatically.
Wow.
And that's directly related
to aging.
So, the idea is you should save
these young, healthy stem cells
so that, potentially
in later years,
you can use it as a therapy
to avoid expensive surgeries,
or really to even avoid
the onset of disease.
So, what we've done
is patented the way
to isolate the stem cells
from the reproductive tissue
that they throw in the trash
when you get a spay and neuter.
Screw the dogs.
I'm gonna do this myself.
You can do stem cells ‐‐
I would recommend you do it.
It changed my life.
Completely changed my life.
You'd have
to be neutered first.
[ Laughter ]
O'Leary:
I don't like that part.
Aaron, let's just
walk through
some of the common sense
elements of this.
Please.
I'm in sports, right?
And so if it was just as simple
as stem cell injections,
you just give a shot,
everything would grow back,
injuries would never matter,
correct?
Well, sounds like a great dream
to me, yeah.
I mean, but my point is,
if it worked,
anybody with a decent doctor
would be doing it.
Why do you think
that's not happening?
John: Well, Mark ‐‐
But I think the reality here
is also this is about the dogs.
I absolutely believe
there is a huge pet market.
You know, people love trying
to take care of their dogs.
As much as you're right,
this is not standard of care
for humans,
but there's a whole world
that comes
where you can actually do
research first on animals.
I'd like to spend a little time
on the reason you're here.
‐Yes.
‐Your business.
Regardless
on the skepticism,
let's start
with the consumer side.
Wonderful.
How much does it cost me
to get the kit?
Our goal is
to make this accessible.
So, we charge only $95 a year
to store your stem cells.
So, every year, I pay you $95,
you hit my card every year.
‐Correct.
‐I get the kit for free.
The kit, we send
to your veterinarian.
So, you don't even have
to worry about it.
The consumer buys it
on our website.
And does the vet
make money?
That's one channel.
And the vet,
it's a revenue stream for them.
How much
are they making?
They make about $100 ‐‐
a "collection fee."
You instantly lose money
on the initial acquisition...
Correct.
...because you're paying
the vet.
Correct.
How much does it cost you
to do the extraction?
So, it costs us ‐‐
Including the cost of the kit,
shipping, everything,
it's about $275 right now.
Including
what you pay the vet?
Uh, no,
plus if we pay the vet.
So it's $375
right out the door?
Most vets
don't even want that.
They just want to kind of do it
for free, or...
And what is it costing you
to operate the business,
your burn rate?
So, we're burning about
$400,000 a month right now,
most of that on R&D.
Are there
any other investors?
So, we have raised a total
of $10 million
to fund this business.
$10 million. Okay.
From who?
I've hired some
of the top ‐‐
What was the last valuation
on the round?
$25 million,
the same as my ask.
How much money do you anticipate
having to raise
at the time you're gonna
launch your product?
'Cause you don't have
any marketing money
available to you yet.
Yeah, so, we will have
to raise money again.
How much?
We'll raise money again
in 2021,
probably $25 million.
Your acquisition costs,
that's what makes me
the most anxious here
about what you're doing
is that for every sale you have,
you're losing money.
Yeah.
You know,
you're gonna sink.
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but Anne is concerned
about the business model
of Aaron's stem‐cell‐banking
company for pets, Gallant.
For every sale you have,
you're losing money.
Yeah.
You know,
you're gonna sink
because you're not gonna have
the cash flow to support that.
So ‐‐
Well, we ‐‐ We're
well‐capitalized now.
I have very good investors ‐‐
a great investor network.
You're not.
But you're not.
You can't sell anything.
I mean, I think there's
a couple things that concern me.
I mean, one thing 23andMe does,
we make money on every kit.
But it makes me
really nervous
that you're gonna
lose money
on every single kit
going out the door,
and it's gonna be
a couple years to recapture.
John: Well, listen here ‐‐
It takes a little while.
Let me tell you
something.
If Anne's nervous,
I'm out.
[ Laughter ]
Daymond, you know
what it's like to love a pet.
I mean, how can you
not support it?
Listen, I'm on the Petco board,
the foundation board.
You'd be such a great partner
for this.
But if Anne's nervous,
I'm out.
Thank you.
I like a lot of aspects
of this business.
This is
an emerging science.
Yeah.
The research is gonna take
years to do,
but the consumer business,
which is gonna be
your foundation for research
and for therapeutics
and all this coming
is a money‐loser.
It's a money sink.
And so unless I ‐‐
like ‐‐
Perhaps
in the very short term, yeah,
but, I mean, when we're creating
this brand‐new market ‐‐
I would say for me,
give me some kind of hope
about how does
that $275 go down.
‐Raise prices.
‐Raise prices to $399,
which actually is
not potentially a bad idea.
Cuban: Exactly.
Like, raise prices here.
Your volume is definitely
gonna go down,
but at least
you're not hemorrhaging
on the consumer side.
Yeah, our perspective is that,
because it's
a brand‐new market
that nobody knows
anything about,
we're doing everything
we can
to lower those barriers to entry
in the beginning...
Right.
...to create word of mouth,
to create virality,
to get the vet on.
When 23andMe launched,
we launched at $1,000,
and in some ways, there was
a benefit of doing that
because you get
the early adopters...
Yeah. Understood.
...you can work out
some of those kinks,
you always want to treat
those customers then great.
Yeah.
But then take down
the price.
Perhaps you're right
that at scale,
there's a better
pricing structure.
Yeah.
All right, Aaron,
because I'm so creative
and I've been
listening to you ‐‐
Cuban: Oh, Lord.
And my juices
are flowing.
I love the space.
I'm in the space.
I know.
And I am Mr. Wonderful.
Here's two offers.
You choose
between them.
I'll give you
the $500,000,
I want the 2%, plus
I want another 2% in options.
So, then I'm basically
getting in at $12.5 million
because of the value
I bring.
Or I'll give you the $500,000,
I want 1% equity,
and $10 off every kit
in perpetuity.
That gets me so incentivized
to sell these kits for you,
you have no idea.
Think about that while everybody
else natters in the background.
That is very creative.
Of course it is.
I really think that's
a clever way of doing it.
Of course it is.
And you'd be
a great partner.
Of course I'd be a great
partner. I love it.
Aaron, I'll simplify things.
Look, I believe
in stem cells, right?
I believe in
what you're trying to do
in terms of the storage.
I just don't think
you've got it figured out,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
All right, thank you, Mark.
Good luck.
Thank you.
So, I think there's a lot
of potential in this business.
Thank you.
I think with Lori,
we could actually
really do a lot
to get this out
direct‐to‐consumer initially.
I believe
in the long‐term potential.
But we're looking
at coming in together
at $500,000 for 8%.
Whoa.
I really believe in this.
Hirschhorn: Thank you.
I know quite a bit
about it,
and I just think that,
you know, down the road,
a lot of things
will be figured out,
but you're
in the beginning.
I think Anne is
a great partner,
so I'm really excited
to work with her.
I think ‐‐
8%.
I'd love to figure out a way
to make this work.
Look, I've got employees
that I've given a lot of equity,
I've got top scientists who
basically took a chance on me.
I got to protect them, too.
But what I think
is important, too, is,
is them knowing the benefit
of having us on your team.
Yes.
Because we can give you
so much help.
So, what are you gonna do,
Aaron?
You've got to make
a decision.
I know. Lori, Anne,
would you guys do 4%?
[ Chuckles ] Oh.
So I'll give you 4%
of the business
'cause I see the value
that you bring.
And we're off to the races.
♪♪
[ Whispering ] Do you want
to counter with 5%?
Yeah.
Would you do 5%?
♪♪
You got a deal.
Done! Great.
Whoo!
Gonna be exciting.
Yeah!
Yeah.
[ Both cheering ]
‐Group hug.
‐Whoo!
Oh! Thank you guys.
I'm so excited.
‐Well...
‐This is gonna be awesome.
‐Gonna be good.
‐Exciting.
‐Thank you.
‐Yeah.
Good job.
Thank you for ‐‐
There you go.
Good luck.
[ Laughs ]
We don't get to keep them?
Yeah, why didn't I get
to keep the puppy?
I get them.
Bye. Thank you, guys.
I'm so shocked.
You're shocked?
No, that Fred
didn't pee on me.
Hirschhorn: I did not expect
Anne and Lori to team up.
Totally surprising, but
they're honestly the dream team,
because Anne is
a perfect partner, Lori, like ‐‐
Nobody knows better
how to explain things
to consumers and the world.
This is ‐‐ I mean, you can see,
even Fred's happy.
♪♪
I grew up in the Bay Area.
My father's a professor
of particle physics,
and my mom is
a high‐school teacher.
Education was everything
for my parents.
My parents said all the time,
"If you do nothing in life,
get an education,"
and that you should do in life
what you really love doing.
I always loved science.
For me, molecular biology
is the most interesting thing
you could possibly study,
so I went into Yale
as a biology major.
After graduating college,
I got an amazing job
working on Wall Street.
I was investing
in healthcare companies,
and I could dig
into the science
and understand healthcare.
I started working
in the late '90s,
and the human genome
had just been sequenced.
There was
this incredible enthusiasm
about the potential of biotech
in curing diseases,
but no one makes money
off preventing disease.
So, I started to realize
that the ship
is pointing
in the wrong direction.
There's amazing potential
of what we could do
that's actually gonna help
people be healthier.
23andMe really came out of
knowing how the system works,
knowing that it's not focused
on really keeping me healthy,
and that the system
doesn't believe in my ability
as an individual
to handle the information
and to step up
and take care of myself.
23andMe is a genetic test
that empowers you
to learn about your ancestry
and your health.
So they're gonna benefit
from prevention,
they're gonna benefit
from treatments.
What else is it that
they could benefit from?
Today, 23andMe has grown
into a community
of over 10 million people.
We're one of
the largest communities
that is advancing
genetic knowledge.
And over here
is just gonna be offices.
I love doing something
that has never been done before.
We're trying to improve
healthcare,
and it's really hard
to change a massive system.
I thrive in an environment
of challenge
and problem‐solving,
so I love doing
what I'm doing.
My primary advice
for entrepreneurs
who are just starting out
is whatever they're doing today,
it's gonna be harder.
Just hold on tight,
ride the ride, and stick to it,
because you can overcome
almost anything.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a modern
version of a favorite food.
♪♪
[ New York accent ] Yo, Sharks,
how y'all doing today?
My name is Mrs. Jenny Goldfarb,
and I'm from the mean streets
of New York City.
I'm a fast‐talking,
no‐nonsense city girl,
and I'm here seeking $100,000
for 10% on my business,
Unreal Deli.
Capiche?
Capiche. [ Laughs ]
[ Chuckles ]
[ Normal voice ] Now, although
I hail from New York City,
about a decade ago, I moved
to beautiful, sunny Los Angeles.
There, I shed the pesky accent.
What I didn't shed ‐‐
my deep love
for the authentic delis
New York is famous for.
I wanted corned beef,
I wanted pastrami,
I wanted it stacked thick on rye
with Russian and mustard
and all the fixin's.
[ Chuckles ]
So, you can imagine my dismay
when I became vegan
and realized I couldn't eat
my beloved corned beef
or pastrami at all.
That's why I created
Mrs. Goldfarb's Unreal Deli,
home of the most mouthwatering,
decadent vegan corned beef.
That's right, Sharks,
at Mrs. Goldfarb's Unreal Deli,
we use nothing
but 100%, super‐clean,
plant‐based ingredients
that are low in carb,
low in fat,
and protein‐packed
to make our Unreal Deli meat.
Don't just take my word for it.
Please dig in
and try for yourselves.
Let's go!
A little closer to you there
is our sweeter rendition
with my signature
Russian dressing
and some apple slaw.
Further back, a little more
of a zinger
with kraut and spicy mustard.
Has a little bit
of a pastrami punch to it.
Not bad.
It's good.
Thank you.
I wanted to create
a healthy rendition...
It's actually really good.
...to the classic deli meat
I grew up on,
which is why I use ingredients
like beets, chickpeas, tomatoes,
and a complex spice blend
to make my deli meat
not only delicious,
but also incredibly nutritious.
Sharks, I'm a fighter,
and I'm gonna keep fighting
until our Unreal Deli meat
is in every grocery store, deli,
and restaurant worldwide.
[ Laughs ]
So, Sharks,
[New York accent]
who wants to sell some meat?
Or do I gotta break some knees
around here?
[ Laughter ]
Jennifer, what's the calorie
count on a sandwich?
[ Normal voice ]
100 per 2 ounces.
‐Oh, that's really good.
‐That's good.
That's great.
It's really good.
It's super low in fat.
That's not bad.
So, who came up
with the formula for this
and developed it?
I came up with the recipe.
I became vegan
about five years ago.
I ate meat my whole life,
and then I started seeing videos
of animal cruelty,
documentaries,
and it was so heartbreaking,
I couldn't stand to continue
to eat the way I was eating.
And I had
a meat‐and‐potatoes husband
and some young kids,
and I had to figure out
how to reconfigure
my cooking methods.
So, I bought every
vegan cookbook I could find,
and I figured out how to cook
from the produce aisle
and the grains aisle.
Ultimately, the food
started getting good,
and so I realized
there are a lot
of delicious burgers
on the market
in the plant‐based world,
but there was no authentic,
classic deli meat.
So, how long
have you been doing this?
Only a handful of months.
We just incorporated
this year.
Right now, we're at about
a half a dozen
of the largest, most iconic
delis around Los Angeles.
But next month, we're coming
into 58 Whole Foods stores.
You are?
Starting in January,
we're gonna be in two 30‐plus
chain restaurants.
What's your history
prior to this?
My history actually goes back
almost 100 years.
My great‐grandfather emigrated
from Romania.
There he is in the middle.
I never had the pleasure
of meeting him.
He emigrated from Romania
as a teenager,
not speaking the language,
without his parents.
So did mine ‐‐
one of mine, by the way.
I know.
I was just thinking,
for us to be sitting here
on this stage today,
it's like, what our parents
and grandparents
did for us to get here.
It's incredible.
I know.
He came from Romania,
started working
as a dishwasher
in his first New York City deli,
and then went on to come
and own and operate
several New York City delis
and cafeterias.
So, corned beef, pastrami,
this is in my bloodline.
So, how are the sales now
in the delis?
So, we're brand‐new,
we're just a few months in,
and in this time,
we've pulled off
$10,000 from the local delis,
and we just launched ‐‐
just a week ago ‐‐
our e‐commerce,
cold‐chain store,
and we sold $2,000
in the first 24 hours it was up.
We didn't even put
any advertising into it.
What do you sell it for,
and what's your cost?
I pay $3.80 per pound
to have it made,
and I sell it for an average
between $8 to $10 a pound.
Now, Jennifer, I have to ask you
this question, okay?
Please.
There are two very large,
well‐capitalized,
public companies
doing plant‐based meats.
What stops them from doing
this derivative of meat
and crushing you like the
corned beef cockroach you are?
Because I'm gonna start working
with one of you,
and we're gonna bring this
to market.
Good answer!
Good answer.
John: Jennifer,
why so much, the value?
I mean, you're asking
for $1 million valuation,
but at such an early stage.
Agreed.
'Cause I'll be honest,
I invested in one
of those companies
that's on the market...
Yeah.
...and I made three times
the amount
of money you're asking for
in a matter of three weeks.
That's good.
And I didn't have to make
any calls,
I didn't have
to do anything.
Okay.
So, why this valuation
of $1 million?
Fair enough.
Because there are teams
of plant‐based investors
out there,
and they've already come
knocking on my door,
and they're ready to give me
half a million
for 10% of my business.
So, why are you here?
Why would you offer it to us
for $100,000?
I'll tell you why.
I've been waiting. Why?
Are you ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Because one Shark dollar
is worth five regular dollars.
‐Yes, that's right!
‐You're so right.
So, why so much,
the valuation?
That's the point, right?
Aren't you saying
that we bring value
to this?
Yes.
But I bring value, too.
She's giving it to you
at a fraction
of what she's already been
offered.
I bring value, too.
My projections ‐‐
$3 million next year.
Well, you haven't lost
your New York hustle.
‐I know, right?
‐No, no, you're right.
Listen, my projection
for next year
is that I'm gonna look like
the guy who plays Thor.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Fair enough, fair enough.
It's not gonna happen,
most likely.
Okay.
Jennifer, do you have
any flexibility
in your equity?
Because I find it
a little light.
I don't think
you're worth half a mil.
Yeah, it is light.
I came here to negotiate.
‐Okay.
‐I can't give away a huge piece.
Yeah.
I'm gonna throw you an offer.
Let's start this going.
Let's talk, Kevin.
And I will help you.
As Chef Wonderful, I'm amazing.
Wow.
I'll help sell it.
Okay.
And he's selling beef.
So, I'm thinking
I'll give you the $100,000
and I want 20%.
Thank you for that offer.
Wojcicki:
So, I love this space.
I'm an investor
in other plant‐based foods.
It's a super‐hot space right now
in Silicon Valley.
There's a lot of money
going into this.
So, I'd love if you can help me
get a little bit
more comfortable with,
you know,
why is it with all
the Silicon Valley
money that's coming
and some of those
big companies out there,
it's hard for me to understand
how you can stay protected.
You mean
the cockroach factor.
How is this actually
gonna be ‐‐
Cuban:
So, I'll simplify everything.
How do you deal with
the cockroach factor?
Jennifer,
I'll simplify everything.
Go ahead.
I love it.
Yeah.
I went vegetarian.
Yeah!
I'll make you an offer
that ‐‐
You know my style, right?
I like the whole "yes or no,
let's negotiate right now."
Oh, it's crap.
It's crap.
I'll give you $250,000...
$250,000?
...for 20%.
Okay.
But this is right now,
do or die?
Do or die,
tell me what you want to do.
So, more than
what you were asking ‐‐
More than what
you were asking for.
Tell me what you want to do.
I'll be on the front page of it,
I'll be the poster child
for it,
we'll hustle.
Mark Cuban,
you got yourself a deal.
‐That's what's up!
‐Whoo!
Very, very smart.
I don't hustle,
I don't mess around either.
Oh, sir.
Thank you so much.
Love the company.
Wow.
Congrats, Jennifer.
Thank you, guys!
Thank you!
Now that I have a deal
with Mark,
the future of Unreal Deli
is extraordinary.
We thought we were doing
great things before.
Just wait and see
what's gonna come.
This business is a cash cow.
We're making cash,
and we're saving the cows.
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an innovation
in the fitness field.
♪♪
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Carnac, here we come.
Greetings and salutations,
Sharks.
I am the Sultan of Sweat.
[ Chuckles ]
I am seeking $300,000
in exchange for 15% equity
in my company,
Terra‐Core Fitness.
Now, Sharks, today,
I'm going to gaze deep
into my crystal ball
to share with you
the future...
of fitness.
[ Laughter ]
[ Exhales sharply ]
Actually, Sharks,
my name's Greg Nigro.
I don't need this hat.
[ Chuckles ]
I don't need
whatever this thing is,
and I certainly don't need
this crystal ball
for you guys to see
that fitness trends
are shifting rapidly.
People want interactive apps,
live streaming content,
versatile, easy‐to‐use equipment
that provide fast results
and a fun experience.
Now, our product checks
all those boxes.
With hundreds of exercises
and only three square feet,
the future of fitness is...
The Terra‐Core!
The Terra‐Core makes
working out fun
and effective
for all fitness levels.
It's 28 pounds and 46 inches
with a patented,
dynamic air‐filled surface
that's comfortable, reactive,
and activates four times
the muscle tissue.
We can lay on it
for bench press,
crunches, and leg lifts.
Judy's doing a bench press.
You can see that her spine
is fully supported
and she's super comfortable.
We can also lift the Terra‐Core
with overhead press,
burpees,
and bent‐over rows.
Tony's doing a burpee,
which is one of our tribe's
favorite exercises.
We can balance on it.
Judy's doing a bird dog.
She's getting tons of
core activation right now.
We can also stand on it
to do squats and lunges.
Tony's activating more muscle
tissue than a standard squat.
We can also jump on it
for agility training
and sports performance.
And that's not all.
Flip it over, and we have
a whole new playground.
With handles and side bars,
we can do tons of push, pull,
and rotational movements
while our band bridges
keep resistance bands
from slipping, sliding,
and pinching.
The Terra‐Core provides
incredible results,
versatility, durability,
and an experience that both gyms
and consumers love.
Sharks, as you can see,
big things ‐‐
and in this case,
big results ‐‐
come in small packages.
Who'd like to come on down
and experience
the future of fitness?
‐Oh, I'd love it.
‐Yeah, let me get some of that.
‐Alright.
‐I'm down.
[ Laughs ]
So, the first thing
that I would probably suggest
is on the soft side,
we'll start here,
with maybe doing
some planks.
Yeah.
There you go.
Greiner: Is it harder?
And so one of the things
that people really love
about our product
is the comfort.
Uh, that's what I was just gonna
say, it's comfortable.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐Yeah, it's very comfortable.
Nigro: Thank you. Yeah.
I prefer that.
Cuban: Come on, DJ, let's have
a push‐up contest.
John: I can't.
I blew my shoulder out.
Those are nice.
Thank you.
Greiner:
What'd you think?
Do you like it better
than traditional?
Yeah, because you're balancing
your body,
so I felt it also in my neck,
you know,
at the same time,
because of the stability.
Well, I wonder about people
actually standing
on this at work.
Yeah,
I do it all the time.
You know, everyone
in Silicon Valley
wants a standing desk.
O'Leary: Not so easy.
It's not easy.
So, I get it.
It is very, very cool.
Thank you.
How many exercises
you said exist with this?
[ Exhales sharply ]
I can't pinpoint a number
because I keep seeing new stuff
on Instagram.
What's your background?
So, I've been in
the fitness industry 20 years.
So, I used to be the
vice president of franchising
for Gold's Gym,
and we started this,
we launched it
on a Kickstarter back in 2016.
We started selling the product
in 2017.
Since that time, we got a
lifetime sales of $2.1 million.
‐Wow. That's great.
‐Thank you.
What did you raise
on Kickstarter?
We raised $95,000.
And where are you selling
predominantly?
We sell into
the commercial markets.
So, we're doing pretty well
with gyms.
So, we're 38% commercial and
we're 38% direct‐to‐consumer,
and the rest makes up
our international
and domestic distribution.
So, what does it cost to sell,
and what does it cost
to make?
So, we've been trying
to figure out the price point.
So, we're actually moving
our price point to $199.
And where has it been?
At $279.
Okay.
$199's better.
Much better.
As soon as we drop
below that $200,
the needle just goes ‐‐
swht! ‐‐ like that.
What does it cost?
And what does it cost
to make one landed?
It landed is $73.
Ooh.
And that's the other reason
why we're here.
‐That's a little risky.
‐It is, it is.
Are you making
in China?
Yes, we're making it in China,
and that includes the tariffs.
And how low
could the cost of goods go?
We believe we can get it
to around $40 to $45.
O'Leary: And are you going
to make any money
in this calendar year?
We're gonna do $850,000
this year.
And will you make
any money?
We will break even this year,
we'll turn a profit next year.
We're projecting $1.4 million
next year.
We'll make $200,000 on that.
So, with cash flow,
we have enough
to where we can go get
inventory, but not enough.
That's why we're struggling
to grow a little bit
because we don't have
the inventory.
Is this patented?
It is.
We have a design patent issued,
we have
a utility patent pending.
I'm gonna make you
an offer.
And I like it, so...
Thank you.
$300,000 for 40%.
‐Ha!
‐You savage.
I appreciate the offer,
Daymond.
Kevin's rubbing off on you,
What are you
talking about?
I'm trying to stretch him,
you know?
I try to teach the grasshopper,
but he's so greedy.
You can always counter,
but remember,
a lot of times, entrepreneurs
come up here and say,
"Will you give us more capital
if needed?"
I usually go, "No."
Okay.
I know in this instance
that I will have to do that.
O'Leary:
I'll make you an offer.
Um...
Do you do Instagram ads,
do you do Facebook ads?
Do you want to hear the offer,
or you want to hear more noise?
Like, what is your
direct‐to‐consumer selling?
I would like to hear both.
Yeah, so...
[ Laughs ]
I would like to hear both.
O'Leary: She's talking
about Instagram,
and I'm about to make you
an offer.
Do you mind if Kevin wants
to give me an offer
and then I can answer
your question?
Yeah.
I like sales.
I like cash flow.
Oh, no.
I like sales. I like sales.
I like it, too.
We have that in common.
The product has merit,
no question.
Thank you.
So, I'll do the $300,000
for 15%,
'cause I'm not greedy
like Daymond.
But I want $20 a unit
in royalty.
But not forever.
Okay.
[ Laughs ]
The royalty goes away
when I hit a million bucks.
I get three times and
a little bit more on my money.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Whoa.
Cuban: Kevin,
you greedy savage.
Please, the name
is Mr. Wonderful.
[ Laughs ]
Greg, you got a beautiful offer
on the table.
And the reason why I ‐‐
Let me explain
why I value that.
Daymond, not to cut you off,
I would love to work with you,
and I appreciate the offer,
but 40% is past
where we can go.
You can always counter.
Okay.
I'd do $300,000 for 20%
if that would be a place ‐‐
You came in for 15%.
Yeah.
Yeah, well, wait.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Let's ‐‐ There are
other people here
that are interested.
So, can I just understand ‐‐
Like, one thing that always
worries me also
about the fitness industry
is that you get a fad,
and then it's done.
So, what is there ‐‐
I love recurring revenue.
Yes.
Like, is there anything?
Is there an app?
Is there anything else?
Yes.
A subscription coming?
Yes, we have a free workout app
right now.
So, in that app, we have
workouts that we designed,
but we also have a tribe,
we're building a community,
and what's really exciting is a
lot of the people from our tribe
want to put their workouts
in our app,
so we're doing that.
The other thing that
we're looking to do is drive
and create
some premium content.
I'd like to move eventually
into a subscription model.
I'm going from 40%
to 35%
'cause you are just
so convincing.
To go back
to the fad question,
is, you know,
I think fad devices
or fad products
are kind of gimmicky.
Yeah.
I don't really view this
as a gimmick.
You mean like standing
on a little piece of plastic,
a plastic board,
and twisting your hips.
Let's talk about my little
plastic piece of board.
Okay.
The Simply Fit Board.
Did a lot of money.
We did $100 million in sales
in one year.
And now, to date, we are
at $180 million
in retail sales.
Wow.
But how many people are
still using it 30 days later?
‐Greg, that's a fad.
‐And just the other day ‐‐
No, it's not a fad.
It is a fad.
It's still in stores.
How many people
do you have ‐‐
Lori, that's not the proof.
Let me finish.
It's still in stores everywhere.
And it's still in storage
at everybody's house.
I run into people every day
that tell me
that they use it
every single day.
‐Right.
‐I don't see it anymore!
It's gone!
No, no, no.
They made their money.
It's gone!
Yeah, right.
Here's the thing,
you run an infomercial,
you can have
tremendous success.
I'll make you an offer.
I'm gonna do $300,000,
22.5%.
22 ‐‐ What are you, trying to
kill me over here?
Okay. Thank you, Lori.
I'm gonna take
my offer down...
Okay.
...to $300,000 for 30%.
Thank you, Daymond,
I appreciate that.
I'm at $300,000
for 22.5%.
Mine's the best offer.
It's 15%.
But ‐‐
But you have a royalty,
Kevin.
So, I'll give you
an offer.
I'll give you the $300,000
for 17%.
Okay.
And I want $10 a board.
‐Ooh.
‐Savage.
Yeah, the royalty thing's
gonna be really hard for us.
In perpetuity.
‐Ooh!
‐Forever?
Savage.
O'Leary: Wait a second.
You realize the difference
between my royalty deal
and Anne's,
she's in perpetuity.
You guys do realize
that I have two offers
with no royalties, right?
Exactly.
Yeah, but they're much
higher equity.
Much higher equity.
You have to value the equity.
‐I understand that.
Here's the thing.
I like it, I want to do it,
I think I gave you
a really good offer.
You did.
♪♪
I'll take it.
‐Whoo!
‐You got a deal.
Yay.
Come on up here.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much.
I'm like, "What are you
thinking about?"
[ Both laugh ]
I'm super excited.
Cuban: Congrats.
Great.
Thank you, guys,
I appreciate it.
Good luck to you all.
O'Leary: Ciao.
Having Lori as a partner means
everything to our business.
We've worked really hard
to get to this point,
and Lori is somebody
who can really take us
to the next level.
Well, Lori said something
about building
her Simply Fit Board
to $100 million,
so next year,
$100 million, maybe?
[ Laughs ]
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a new idea
in the outdoor furniture space.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks,
my name's Jiake Liu.
And I'm Terry Lin.
We're the co‐founders
of Outer.
We're seeking $750,000
in exchange for 4% equity stake
in our company.
‐Come on, man.
‐Ooh.
Imagine for a moment,
it's early in the morning,
the house is still quiet.
Your coffee
just finished brewing.
It's a perfect spring day.
The birds are chirping.
You look outside
at your outdoor sofa.
Coffee in hand,
you inhale deeply...
Ohh!
The cushions are wet,
and now so are my pants!
We call that
the soggy bottom syndrome.
Sharks, that's just one
of many problems
with outdoor furniture.
It falls apart easily,
it's very uncomfortable,
or they're stored
in the garage somewhere,
never to be used.
At Outer, we've solved
all of those problems.
We've created
the perfect outdoor sofa
that's as comfortable
as your bed
and as durable
as your camping equipment,
all while using
eco‐friendly materials.
Most importantly,
no more soggy bottoms
with our patent‐pending
invention,
the Outer Shell Cover.
Let me show you
how it works.
In the evening, all you have
to do is cover up,
and then pull
the Outer Shell over,
and the cushion
is completely protected
from the elements.
If you know there's
a rain storm coming,
all you have to do is take it
and go with you.
Greiner: Wow.
So, it's very easy to carry
and store.
John: Very cool.
And the next morning,
there's gonna be a layer
of morning dew on here,
but all you have to do
is open it up,
flip it open.
The perfect sofa
ready for you to enjoy.
So, we've created
the perfect outdoor sofa,
but we realized
that the shopping experience
wasn't great.
Typically, when you see
an outdoor sofa,
you see it inside,
in a climate‐controlled
environment
where it never has
seen sun, rain, or bird poop.
So, we've actually
revolutionized
the shopping experience.
We've developed
a proprietary,
peer‐to‐peer showroom
platform.
It's where we convert
our customer's showrooms
into our showrooms,
and in doing so,
customers can see, touch,
and feel the sofa
before they decide to buy.
It's something that we call
a Neighborhood Showroom.
It's a sharing economy
for retail.
Liu: So, Sharks,
who is ready to join us
to bring life outside?
O'Leary:
How much does the sofa cost?
So, the sofa you're looking at
right now,
the three‐seater
is $2,500.
‐$2,500?
‐Okay.
Greiner:
I don't think that's bad.
What does it cost you
landed?
So, each chair is $800.
They're modular,
by the way.
Each retail cost is $825
when you average it out.
And then the cost of goods made
is about $225 or so.
‐$225.
‐Yep, landed.
So, I want to make sure
I understand this,
is instead of having
a showroom
where you have your own
retail space, so to speak,
your customers
are opening up their backyards?
Exactly. Yeah, you got it.
Do I understand that right?
You got that perfectly,
yeah.
So, what do I get paid
for allowing that to happen?
Yeah, so, we're testing that
right now,
and, uh, you're expected to make
about $20 to $50 per visit.
And the platform that we built,
you have to book a visit.
You can't just show up to
somebody's home randomly, right?
I get it.
So, $750,000, 4% computes
$18.7 million.
‐Good math.
‐Yeah.
Why is this worth
$18‐plus million?
So, Kevin, so,
the outdoor furniture
market in the U. S.
is a $9 billion market.
Oh, that's the worst answer!
No, don't go by that.
Don't go by that.
Do you watch the show?
That's a very bad thing
to say.
Kevin, how big is the bankruptcy
market in the U. S.?
It's really, really big.
But go ahead, Jiake.
Uh, we just launched
about four months ago,
and we did about $800,000
in sales to date.
But you haven't made
any money yet, have you?
We're not
making money yet.
Why $18 million?
What's the reason?
Yeah, um, so, we ‐‐
First of all, we just closed
our last round
with our
VC‐backed investment.
At what valuation?
That was
a $13.5 million valuation.
So you came into the Shark Tank
and raised it even more?
How much do you project
this year?
This year, we're gonna close out
at least $1 million.
Next year,
we're projecting $5 million.
Greiner: So,
how many partners do you have,
and what percentage
of the company do you two own?
I own 60%,
Terry owns 25%,
and my family factory
owns 15%.
So, another answer
to the valuation
is because it's actually
taking out
the risk
on the supply chain.
So, they're essentially
giving us this at cost, right?
Your family is subsidizing you
by not taking a margin
because they own 15%
of the business?
That's right.
Interesting.
And we don't have to pay for
the inventory until we sell it.
That's interesting.
So, guys, uh...
You know the valuation's crazy.
You know, you're gonna...
You only sold $800,000,
hopefully $1.5 million,
and you're valuating
at over $18 million.
You know exactly what's gonna
happen to you here, right?
So I'm out.
Wojcicki: So, for me,
coming from Silicon Valley,
I'm used to seeing massive
valuations all the time,
and, frankly, I've way overpaid
for a number of deals
that I think can potentially
change the world
or actually have
a huge impact.
I don't think
it's world‐changing for me,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
Hey, guys, I think
it's a great business.
Could it be
a $100 million business?
Yeah, it really could be.
But look at it from my end,
right?
Let's just say you do
$200 million.
‐Sure.
‐And your margins are 10%.
Net margins,
you'd be thrilled to death.
You're making $20 million,
I'm making 5% of that.
I mean, that's not bad money,
but the risk‐reward versus what
you're asking just is not there.
But current DTC brands
have a multiple
of anywhere
from three to ‐‐
Yeah, that's great,
and you found the VCs
that pay those kind
of multiples, right?
Mm‐hmm.
That ain't me.
That's not "Shark Tank."
For those reasons, I'm out.
I like it.
I really do.
But I don't mean any disrespect
to the previous VCs.
They are not Mr. Wonderful.
I am.
You may not like this offer,
but I'm going to make it
anyways.
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out,
but Kevin seems interested
in Terry and Jiake's outdoor
furniture company, Outer.
You may not like this offer,
but I'm going to make it
anyways.
Now, traditionally,
to get back my capital,
I would want some kind of
cash flow
in the form of, you know,
maybe I'd make a debt,
or maybe I'd make a royalty.
But I'm in a generous mood
today. I'm feeling frisky.
Oh, my Lord.
[ Chuckles ]
So, I'm gonna give you $750,000,
straight equity.
I want 20%.
[ Laughs ]
I don't care
if he laughs.
He didn't give you
any money.
Um...
I would love to hear Lori.
I love it.
I want to be part of it.
But you've just
started selling it.
How about this?
Let me throw a different type
of offer at you.
So, give you a $750,000 loan
as a line of credit,
but I want $20
in royalty per chair.
The royalty
until I get paid back
the $750,000
into $1 million.
Hmm.
And then at the end
of the day,
I'll have 10% of the company.
Yeah.
You know, grasshopper,
you've learned
from the master.
[ Laughter ]
Lin: That sounded like
your kind of deal, I know.
There's only one Mr. Wonderful,
and he is amazing.
I could easily do that deal
and even beat it,
'cause that's my kind of deal.
She ‐‐ Basically, Lori
learned that from the master.
Would you match
that deal?
Or how would you beat
Ooh, if you want him
to match my deal
and you would pick him,
then I'm gonna go out.
Wouldn't do that.
I'll do it.
No.
‐Ooh.
‐I'll do the deal.
I'll do her deal.
Seriously,
you're gonna lose me,
and that
you will regret forever.
‐Can we talk?
‐I'll do her deal.
‐Can we talk about this?
‐Forever.
Mm.
Let's talk about it.
He's gonna match my deal.
No, wait, wait, let me squeeze
her head a little bit.
You should not even
have to think about that.
Let me do you a favor.
I feel like five, four,
three, two...
No, no, no,
I'll do them a favor.
...say yes now.
I'll do her deal.
My deal could evaporate.
Wait, wait, wait.
No, don't.
Mnh‐mnh. Mnh‐mnh.
I'll do her structure
for 5% equity.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah, baby!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐That's ridiculous.
Just to shake it up.
Make a decision.
Make a decision, guys.
♪♪
[ Indistinct whispering ]
So, I'll go for it.
Yeah, okay.
All right, so, our counter
to Lori's offer
is, um, $750,000 in loan,
and royalty will pay back
to the $750,000,
and on the equity side,
we would love
to bring it down to 4%,
what we asked for
when we came in.
You want me to get up
every morning
and be like, "I can't wait
to blow that up"?
I mean,
you need that passion.
You need that.
And I'm worth it.
I'm worth it.
Kevin's willing to do 5%,
$750,000.
I think
that's really attractive.
But we do want to work with you.
I feel that connection.
So, is there any way
you can match that?
We'll even throw in
the $1 million.
So, it's $1 million paid back
to the royalty, but 5%.
You want to raise
the royalty?
Uh, the royalty ‐‐
You want to kick up
the royalty
and I'll go down
on the percentage?
You can afford it, especially
with how many we'll sell.
Uh, what's your offer
on the royalty?
Well, why don't we go
to $30?
$30 works?
I think $30 works.
$30 works, 5%?
$30 up until $1 million?
So, $750,000 as a loan.
Okay.
I get $30 a chair
until $1 million
is paid off.
Okay.
We'll make it 3% interest
and 5% equity.
Let's do it, Lori.
Let's do it.
Yoo!
Whoo!
That's good.
This is so brilliant
in the outdoor space.
Wait till you see
the other things that
we're coming up with.
Honestly, it's brilliant.
We're working on
so many more products.
Cuban:
Congratulations, guys.
Thank you.
Greiner: Why would you ever buy
anything else?
Congratulations.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you so much.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Congratulations. Congrats.
Wow.
[ Laughs ]
Nice job.
We're not trying to get
the best deal,
we're trying to find
the right partnership.
Kevin actually made
a better offer than Lori,
at the end of the day,
but, you know,
Lori definitely won us over
because of that connection
that we felt with her.
♪♪